what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back again with another installment
of our beyond omega level series where
we discuss the most powerful characters
in comics and in our recent video on
scar son of the hulk one commenter
cosmic dropout pointed out that hulk has
another son who's probably more powerful
than scar named hirokala yes i know we
covered him in our incredible hulk
playlist so that's the one that we're
going to talk about today and we're
going to start by going over his origin
and then moving on to his powers and his
feats so hirokala was created by greg
pack and ron garney and first appeared
in scar son of hulk number two in 2008.
now just like scar hiro caller's origin
is rooted on the planet hulk storyline
which saw the illuminati a group
consisting of charles xavier tony stark
namor blackbull reed richards and doctor
strange basically deciding the hulk was
too dangerous for earth and then sending
him into space on a rocket with the
intention of him going to an uninhabited
world where he would just basically
spend his time in peace because there'd
be nobody around for him to hurt what
happened though is that the hulk ended
up on the war-torn planet known as
sakhar he overthrows the dictator of
sakhar falls in love with a woman named
kaira she gets pregnant and then the
ship that brought the hulk to sakhar
basically blows up and kills her what we
don't know at the time however was that
kiera was actually pregnant with twins
because comics and both of them ended up
surviving the explosion now one of the
twins is scar who's able to survive
because he has the physiology and
therefore the durability of the hulk his
twin hirokala does not have the hulk's
physiology but is able to unwittingly
harness an ancient energy source known
as the old power to save himself by
basically hardening his skin which
allows him to survive the ship's
explosion shortly after this though
hirokala is enslaved on sakhar by a one
lord named axeman bone and after
learning about the old power hirokala
encounters a priest named hiro amin who
had once wielded the old power now hiro
amen then tells hirokala that to get the
old power one must kill someone who
possesses it and naturally this leads to
hero colic healing hero amun but he
doesn't really inherit the old power and
figures out that the priest had actually
lied to him now axeman bone frees
hirokala and then gives him a spot on
his honor guard and they set out to stop
scar who was on the verge of taking the
old power for himself although hirokala
begs scar not to take the old power he
does which prompts a silver surfer to
come to sakaar and challenge scar
himself now hirokala took this
opportunity to free as many slaves as
possible and began amassing an army to
overthrow his brother but galactus comes
to sakaar and basically devours it now
hirokala escapes the planet on a stone
ship saving the last surviving members
of his race in the process and then
reveals that some of the old power still
lives on within him and then promises
that he will make galactus pay for
consuming sakhar now as for his powers
there are three sources from which
hirokala derives his abilities the first
of these of course is the old power
which is an ancient source of energy
that was wielded by the shadow people
the race of aliens that hero kala's
mother belonged to the all power was
created in an attempt to rival the power
cosmic which is basically the power
galactus has and the power the silver
surfer uses but the old power proved to
be much less stable than the power
cosmic and in fact it was so powerful
that it nearly destroyed a quarter of
the known universe now in his quest for
vengeance against galactus hirokala
manages to create a new power which was
a combination of the old power and the
power cosmic that's fueled by hate which
hirokala possesses in abundance due to
the anger he feels towards galactus now
later hirokala's ship would wind up in
the microverse where he finds a planet
called kai and on that planet he
discovers the world mind a sort of
planetary consciousness now hirokal is
able to take control of some of the
world mind's power and uses it to
enslave the people of kai before heading
to earth to confront his brother scar
and so with these three sources of power
it's obvious that hirokala is
ridiculously powerful so let's take a
look at some of the feats that he's
pulled off right first of all he has an
insane level of durability having taken
multiple strikes from the hulk and scar
as well as a blast from a powerful
artifact called the enigma force
nullifier now in addition to his
durability hirokala can use his powers
offensively and he's so powerful that
this battle with scar literally broke a
planet apart he's also able to project
powerful beams and is able to incinerate
enemies at will hirokala also has potent
telekinetic power which allows him to
fly and also make people's heads explode
with his thoughts which is kind of wild
now one of the primary abilities of the
old power is that it allows its wielders
to manipulate the plate tectonic
energies of a planet which means that
basically he can move the plates that
make up a planet around him so he can
use this to tear a planet apart or to
move a planet through space which he did
with the planet kai which he moved from
jupiter to earth in 43 hours that's a
distance of 365 million miles which
means he was moving the planet in excess
of 8.4 million miles per hour now he's
also able to pull the planet kai which
is roughly the size of mars out of its
orbit so we're talking about someone who
can move planets at will that's just a
ridiculous level of power but the thing
hirokala is best known for is poisoning
galactus which he did while galactus was
attempting to devour a planet which
contained a large supply of the old
power and this takes place after
hirokala had basically taken control of
the planet and convinced most of its
citizens that he was a god but
regardless as galactus is devouring this
world hirokala mixes the old power with
the power cosmic which effectively
poisons galactus and causes him to feel
the pain of the souls he was destroying
and this is pretty unfortunate for him
because at this point he's addicted to
the old power but he knows it could
potentially destroy him the next time he
consumes it something else here though
is that hiro kala is able to survive a
blast from galactus although he does
suffer a severe burn in the process now
as powerful as hirocala is however he of
course had to eventually lose to the
good guys and was beaten to the point of
death by his father the hulk but the
whole could not bring himself to kill
his son and so following this hirokala
would be attacked by his brother scar
and the two of them engage in an epic
battle with both of them wielding the
old power until scar manages to gain the
victory by encasing his brother in stone
notice at this point that hiro kala is
absorbed by the core of the planet kai
at the direction of the world mind so
that his power could basically heal that
planet and that's the last we've seen of
hiro kala even when scar tried to
release him from the world minds control
at the hulk's request but was unable to
do so so yeah that's the deal with the
hulk's other son who is insanely
powerful but was only used in a handful
of appearances maybe we'll see him up
here in the comics at some future point
in time i have no idea but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
to an end thank you all for watching and
i will catch you all later
peace